and I'm not going to lie I cheated you
know what I mean I think he taught me
what like real love was he
unconditionally loved me cuz everybody
loves you wow she cheat wow okay he
really just he forgave me multiple times
not the rider die yeah he was a rider I
made a lot of money in my 20s so I never
asked him for um anything financially he
never but then he also never offered
what did you do well I was a stripper
girl so I oh you was making money yeah I
was making money and I needed that
grounding I needed somebody that loved
me unconditionally he seems like a good
guy to be honest he opened all my doors
he drove fast cars he could fight and
she still
cheated what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
and and get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today okay so this video
says women break break down in tears
because men don't want to date her let's
go welcome back family today we are
going to see a woman who breaks down in
tears for being alone but before that
let check out some interesting related
Clips as a warm-up to understand where
this crying is really coming from to the
idea of like speaking to multiple guys
I've always been I feel like in order
for me to actually settle down and like
be with one person I would have to be
getting like the same energy
reciprocated and they'd be having to
really call for me and be like I want to
be with you this is how I feel so the
problem how is a guy going to give you
enough attention to subsidize like
dating let's say five men four men three
men how is the guy going to get you give
you enough attention is it even possible
and then at that point on I'll be like
okay like they're giving all of them to
me like now I'm ready to like fully
commit and be serious to this person but
I think until then the playing field I
don't believe someone should get all
your attention just because it's like
the beginning stage and we're talking
like I I'm not going to close off any
doors to see where this goes until you
reassure me that you're all in and and
that you're solidifying what we have
yeah the dating multiple guys advice is
very popular and pushed to young women
this is just what I call abused
hypergamy a man that values himself will
know when you not giving him all your
attention and he will just walk away the
fear of missing out and trying to have
everything at the same damn time result
into a very lonely life for these young
women check it out maybe this is too
Niche maybe it's not I don't think it is
but it's a beautiful day outside today
it's literally 70° it should not be 70°
in February where I live but that is
that's another video but it's beautiful
outside today and I was like you know
what I'm going to eat my lunch I'm going
to go outside I'm going to sit before
for my next class it's going to be good
I get outside and I look around and I
realize I am quite literally the only
person sitting by myself it just made me
so sad sad to the point where I got up
and I literally went inside and I felt
like I couldn't enjoy the stunning day
that it was today because I was like I'm
so [__] sick of doing stuff by myself
and I don't really feel lonely except in
instances like this and I think this is
why my anxiety and my depression
actually like is worse lonely is a
really common feeling nowadays and I
think it's like because more people are
living in cities actually because I
don't know there's something different
like they say the grass is isn't um like
the Grass Grows Where you water it right
and there's just something about cities
where people are just able to replace
their friend group so easy where if you
go to like a smaller town Town people
have to like work through things and
grow as people and like become a better
person and so I think I think you're
just going to get like and you know
people aren't getting married there's
less families there's less just
Community across the board um so I
actually I want to know where she went
and found couples cuz you don't really
see that like you used to the summer
because I find that during the summer
for whatever reason I'm always like by
myself I have friends don't get me wrong
my friends are incredible I love my
friends they're like my sisters but they
have l lives and I feel like I don't
anytime you see me out 90% of the time
I'm by myself I go to the store by
myself I walk to class by myself I sit
by myself like I'm always alone and it
never bothers me really until it slaps
me in the face that like oh [__]
everyone else is with somebody be it
platonically romantically whatever and
I'm by myself like sitting outside today
like that was like a perfect
encapsulation of like my entire life
like everyone was sitting with someone
and I was literally the only person
sitting alone and in that moment it just
made me so [__] depressed like it
made me so sad and I've had the same
friend since high school and obviously
we were in high school like we saw each
other every day and I texted my friends
and I was like you guys I miss seeing
you guys every day so bad and every time
a beautiful day comes around I'm like I
wish I had someone to like go on a walk
with I wish I had like friends that I
saw more often I wish I had a boyfriend
friends so [__] bad you guys I don't
know but it made me really upset and I
literally got up and I went inside
because I was like this is so [__]
embarrassing now believe me when I tell
you that there is definitely a guy who
is busing those chicks down so when she
says that she is alone she is not really
alone only men feel what being alone
really yeah yeah women are single by
choice there are very few men that
choose to be single women it's always a
choice for the most part was like I can
assure you that she has a lot of men in
her DMS that would treat her right but
she completely ignore them because she
thinks that she can do better like this
next girl he was like a different type
of dude like he didn't even look you
could come shake your ass in his face
and he's just like nope not looking
nowhere you know what I mean that's a
husband where he at now what happened I
know a husband when I hear one I would
say I you know I [__] that up but no
you know he was there for a time and he
was a good man in my 20s but he was a
lot older than me and he was complacent
he was complacent in a certain lifestyle
a certain Financial bracket and there's
just a certain life that I'm always
going to be trying to chase and so it
would have never worked you hear that
there's going to be a life that I'm
always trying to chase and it's a life
that guys it's not most people are
normal most people are average most
people will not get an extravagant
lifestyle and it's funny because the
people that I know that have super that
are well off never chased money it was
never about money in my 30s
oh wow and I'm not going to lie I
cheated you know what I mean I did he
taught me what like real love was he
unconditionally loved me cuz everybody
loves you based on wow wow okay once you
start doing [__] that they don't like
then all of a sudden all these things
start going out the window he really
just he forgave me multiple times not
the rider die yeah he was a rider but he
needed to get his [__] together in terms
of finances I made a lot of money in my
20s so I never asked him for um anything
financially but then he also never
offered what did he do well I was a
stripper girl so you was making money I
was making money money and I needed that
grounding I needed somebody that loved
me unconditionally cuz it just made me
go to the strip club and look at guys
like [__] you a you ain't got [__] for
me um he seems like a good guy to be
honest he opened all my doors he drove
fast cars he could fight he was fine so
he just didn't want and she still
cheated [__] himself a lot of that's a
huge thing I didn't of course this guy
was a s he did a little bit too much by
forgiving her for her debauchery but you
got the point she always wanted more and
more this is the mentality of most
modern women then when they hit the wall
and realize that they are still single
this happens this video isn't going to
have a punch line tell you that right
off the bat um because I am basically
just making it to stop crying um because
usually when I start trying to make
video I stop crying and um
I've been crying all day because I got
sat on a plane next to a couple and the
whole time the guy had his hand on like
his girlfriend's leg you know and it was
just kind of like that the whole
time and
um I just I can't like I've been single
my whole life I'm 25 and I've never
gotten to experience that I've never
gotten like close to that
this is going to be really common it's
already common it's going to become even
more
common it's just too much like it's too
much I can't do it anymore there are
some people out there who they don't
they're not interested in a relationship
and they want to be by themselves but
like that's not me and that's never been
me I have always wanted to be in a
relationship even though I've never been
in one um and even though I'm like I'm
comfortable by myself and I can do
things alone but like at a certain point
it gets like really sad doing things
alone like I've traveled alone to so
many places because like if I don't go
by myself I'm not going to go if I don't
do things by myself it's not going to
happen but at the same time like it's so
much fun to be able to like share that
with someone else and like everyone I
know is in a relationship right now and
like the majority of them have been in
relationships for like a long time like
this is established and I just like I
feel feel like I've always been alone
and I don't want to be and I don't
understand why this is happening to me
and it's because we have an entire
society that lies to women nobody tells
us the truth men don't tell us the truth
the media doesn't tell us the truth even
our mothers and fathers lie to us um and
I just I don't know I like can't take it
anymore um and clearly this didn't work
because I'm still crying and I just
wasted like 2 minutes of your time and
I'm
sorry and I hope you're having a better
weekend than I am so fellas most of the
pain these modern women are going
through are self-inflected so do not
feel sorry for them that's it for
today's video yeah yeah you could put
like a meme like oh is it not the
consequences of my own
actions well if it isn't the
consequences of my own actions what's up
what's
up try but let me know what you guys
think in the comments I do think
feminism has lied to women um let me
know what you guys think get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt and I'll
talk to you next time